stress we all know what it is and we all
handle it differently but it's our
thoughts speeding up or slowing down
eating our emotions or not at all
difficulty sleeping or just getting out
of bed frankly it sucks
but there's good stress too you know
like preparing for the biggest public
speaking event you've ever given
on a global platform now even the good
stress can mess with you but it's the
bad stress that I came to talk about and
probably not for the reason you'd expect
I'm a relationship manager for affluent
individuals meaning I work with wealthy
folks and their families hip-to-hip
helping them achieve their financial
goals I like to keep the economy in mind
because I know that whatever impacts the
economy impacts my clients and it turns
out stress is impacting the economy in a
massive way what if I told you that by
some estimates the cost of work-related
stress in the US is close to 300 billion
dollars annually workplace stress the
stress causing this massive impact is
related to productivity and wellness
today that's we're here to talk about
and by the way it's linked to employee
disengagement chronic diseases that
impact your work and work-related
injuries and illnesses and when you add
up the cost of all five factors
it's an estimated 2.2 trillion dollars
annually that represents 12% of our GDP
now I know what you're thinking that is
a lot of money and how stress is this
deeply personal thing it's crazy to
think that it could have such a massive
impact but consider this thought
experiment to explain how imagine a
single mother working a stressful job in
a stressful environment where she sits
90% of the time maybe she doesn't have
time to cook so she chooses meals based
off of convenience which users means
what
overly processed high sugar foods over
time this poor diet mixed with distress
from work leads to a chronic disease
let's call it diabetes medical care
costs her and the company more money
which means more stress now she's
worried about her health and making ends
meet so she's probably distracted and
less productive but she can't be
remember she's a single mother now she's
thinking what if something happens to me
who's gonna take care of my child who is
gonna take care of my baby or stress
now take that scenario twiki whichever
way you'd like and lay it over the
nation and you might start to see how we
run up against that multi trillion
dollar cost this all hits very close to
home for me my father is one of the
hardest-working and most intelligent
people that I know don't get me wrong
mom worked and provided - but
definitely embraced the role of being
the primary breadwinner and I'm sure
most of us can understand the stress and
pressure that comes with taking care of
our families but when you combine that
with workplace stressed you know what
could happen
developing irreversible high blood
pressure eventually losing function of
your kidneys and spending a decade on
dialysis his faith now I'm happy to
report that he did you two kidney
transplant just last year however
however for nearly a decade
none of the economy nor my family got
the benefit from his work ethic or his
intelligence and has he would say that's
just really sad commentary all I'm
saying is I think stress impacts the
economy by reducing productivity and
increasing health care costs make sense
right but here's what doesn't current
research from the World Health
Organization puts a global spinning on
health at seven point eight trillion
dollars research from the global
Wellness Institute suggests that the
four point five trillion dollar global
onus industry grew from three point
seven to four point two trillion between
2015 and 2017 and sees that growth into
so what why do you care because that
growth is nearly twice as fast as the
global economy averaging about three
point three percent in the same period
so what does all that mean every year
we're spending more per year on health
and the industry is all about developing
overall well-being and living a
healthier lifestyle or growing almost
twice as fast as the global economy and
yet we're losing trillions of dollars
per year in output so what's up well
stress levels are up and I believe that
needs to change I also believe the way
we think about stress needs to change so
let's try by reframing how we view it
see we tend to think about stress as a
consequence but I see it as a culture
where do most of us spend our time at
work right where we face that scale of
finding that work-life balance so the
bonds between work stress health and
wellness have never been closer and yet
there's a massive disconnect and how we
approach stress and well-being in the
workplace and we can play many things
right new tech laser focus on
shareholder returns or
my favorite keeping up with the Joneses
and taking pictures while we try but at
the end of the day I'm afraid that we've
created a culture where personal care
and overall well-being are given the
backseat so how do we move forward I
believe the answer lies in three
fundamental pillars and if you find
yourselves thinking well Rob I've heard
this before tell me something I don't
know ask yourself if we already know
what to do then what have we been doing
first corporations specifically how a
corporation's culture and communication
style play a pivotal role and the stress
and well-being of a workplace the DNA of
a company is its culture right sets the
tone even goes as far as defining the
company but I think companies should
invest in the overall mental physical
and emotional well-being of their
employees the way they invest in
innovation R&D right and do I think that
this would increase productivity and
reduce stress I really do but for it to
really stick a company has to figure out
a way to measure the overall well-being
of its employees with the same accuracy
and precision that they project growth
in earnings and if this sounds like a
tall order ask yourself what really is a
company's most competitive advantage
it's people we know this and just like
anything in a company it has to start at
the top so if you're a leader openly
showing how you care for your mental
health and overall well-being is a huge
catalyst it's no secret I'm a soccer fan
so growing up I had a couple coaches and
I always had one who would lead the
heavy cardio workouts he was he would
not stand on the side inspect him he
would participate and that did three
things it made it difficult for me to
complain I always made sure to keep up
and I always felt more dialed in to the
exercise it's the same idea
and finally communication in order for
me to really help my clients achieve
their financial goals it requires that I
actively listen and then respond let
your employees tell you what stresses
them out let them tell you what wellness
benefits they need and then act and
acting on what they tell you will show
how serious you take that feedback and I
can't help but feel the company will win
in the long run
why because properly equipped employees
will be more productive and less
stressed next I'd like to ask help from
everyone's favorite uncle that's right
the government
to play a role in this the World
Economic Forum in the Harvard School of
Public Health estimate that from 2011 to
major chronic diseases and mental
illnesses will cost a global economy
47 trillion dollars and it's 2020 now
I'm not saying stress causes all major
chronic diseases or all mental illnesses
but even if a portion of it is imagine
how much lower that number could be if
the government did what it does best
serve as the enforcer but in this case
for hire workplace standards I don't
know maybe even corporate tax incentive
programs to help raise those standards
but the best wellness corporate policies
the initiatives backed by a
forward-thinking government won't matter
much without help from the most crucial
pillar you
that's right stress and managing it is
so dynamic you have to play your part
and it's going to benefit you in the
economy look folks I'm not a
psychologist okay but I have taken steps
to develop my own mental health and
overall well-being so here's my last two
cents I think a crucial first step is
for everyone is to be honest with
themselves about what about putting your
mental physical and emotional well-being
in the rearview and the damage it has
caused honest about placing public
opinion above self-preservation think
social media honest about how we define
ourselves and what actually does sure
your career contributes to a portion of
who you are but are we allowing it to
define us just a little too much and ask
is this bringing me the value I saw with
what it costs me and I don't just mean
the dollars for me being honest meant to
gain a good heart look at my
relationship with my thoughts courage
and failure started years ago in this
tournament championship game coach comes
to me and says Rob cook you step up we
can't lose today so I stepped up failed
we lost
thanks for laughing feels good no but
you know after that it stayed with me
for a while and to the point where any
opportunity to step up grow develop I
quietly bow my head step back and then I
discovered mindfulness and I continue to
develop it in my daily life to this day
to live in the present and then now now
I get it mindfulness may not be for
everyone but when I think of some of the
most successful and impactful people I
see a common trend mastery of their
mental game which includes stress
management it's all about developing
awareness acknowledgement and acceptance
of your current thoughts emotions
environment and physical state right now
I didn't say never facing stress but the
management of that stress that's the
benefit again for you in the economy
I'll leave you with this thought we all
know that retirement is all about saving
more now for later what if we treated
our mental health and overall well-being
in the same capacity develop and save
more of you now for later in life doing
nothing means more cost in worse less
time and of the two which can't you get
back so let's start moving this culture
of stress forward and start living
happier healthier and hopefully more
productive lives thank you
[Applause]
[Music]